the Joe Rogan experience did you ever
eat near Raven
no I heard Raven taste good oh I heard
crow
I heard crow taste good I heard it's
very similar to like diver duck look if
you pretty prope prepare correctly you
know diver ducks state yeah like I'm reg
answer some more of a fishy taste to
them oh you mean like yeah like some of
them yeah like ask odor mm-hmm yeah but
apparently Raven the crow you need it
it's good oh you can eat anything it's
whether or not you want to what's the
weirdest [ __ ] you mean weasels weasels
no question that was the weirdest yeah
it was like that hand to mouth period
when ran out of moose meat
caribou didn't show up I was starving I
was literally starving and I was getting
a little bit to eat everyday but I was
running all over the mountains hunting
burning up lots of calories and I can
eat three or four pounds of meat a day
some days all I was eating was a grouse
or something and there were a couple
days when the only thing I brought home
were a couple weasels you know I was
trapping Martin I had Martin traps out
and sometimes weasels go into him and
I've eaten weasel and I'll tell you
somethin bout weasel they smell like a
skunk they got a scent gland
they're terrible you if you ever want to
wheeze weasels for food you've got to
skin it real carefully you don't want to
hit the same gland and then the other
thing about a weasel is if you just fry
them up real hot they're so small you
can eat just about every bone in them
like the legs just crunch crunch crunch
really oh yeah yeah and weasels are
sweet probably carnivorous right so you
probably have to cook right through them
right to live on voles oh yeah oh I
fried them right up until they were like
blonde little mice yeah well voles are
Mouse like rodents that live in the
Brooks Range we don't have real mice Oh
so voles like a cousin of a mouse or
something they're related so you're you
just fry it till it's just everything's
dead yeah hopefully that was that was
not good that was the weird stuff I ever
ate I hope never sisal it's not not good
it depends on how good a job you do skin
on they they smell like a skunk I mean
you know flavors mostly smell is your
family eating this weasel too
at the time Silvia at the time was out
there with me yes she to a Dweezil yeah
she was looking at phrase where she's
eating weasel she had a good attitude
about it she know she was pretty amazing
woman in terms of taken to the bush she
I mean she was an opera singer in Berlin
before she met me yeah isn't really Wow
and and my partner Tricia that I've been
living with the last five years she was
an attorney in Boston why it's yeah Wow
why get that people are always telling
me like you're never gonna find a woman
to live like that out there but actually
it's appealing to certain people I think
a lot of people that's why people watch
on TV people want to be free right yeah
and people want to be alive yeah and a
lot of people don't feel it today it's
true if you spend your whole life in an
office or a courtroom and before that
you were in school you've never really
yeah just feel trapped yeah in the grind
the grind of just keeps showing up at
the office every day and cases are
piling up and like she know she's living
with Glenn by side of a lake
dodging wolves
[Laughter]
[Applause]